il faut sauver le soldat arriva voilà ce
qui pourrait être la devise de l'état
qui ne cessent de voler au secours de
l'entreprise publique en perdition
depuis déjà de nombreuses années à coup
de milliards d'euros
nous sommes ici devant le siège social
d'areva à la défense et après de
nombreux déboires ces derniers temps l
entreprise pourrait bien se retrouver en
cessation de paiement d'ici avril à 2021
la raison cette fois ci elle la
construction d'un réacteur nucléaire
l'un des fameux e p r en finlande
les travaux devaient être terminés en
2009 et force est de constater onze ans
plus tard que le chantier a pris un
léger retard après des difficultés
techniques des surcoûts donc l'
enveloppe allouée au projet elle n'est
plus la même et passerait aujourd'hui de
3 à 10 milliards d'euros
seul problème et il est taillé
l'entreprise publique n'est pas en
mesure de régler la note
c'est donc l'état qui une nouvelle fois
va sortir le carnet de chèques pour un
montant estimé entre 600 et 800 millions
d'euros en plus des 400 millions déjà
signé cet été
et le moins que l'on puisse dire
justement c'est que les déchéances
arrive vite pour éviter la faillite
d'areva à l'état de trouver des
solutions rapidement c'est à dire avant
la mi janvier 2021 d'autant plus que
l'entreprise doit faire face à des
procédures judiciaires qui pourraient
lui coûter très cher à l'avenir
le programme scandinave pourrait donc
voir le jour d'ici à 2023 en grande
partie financé par le contribuable
français
le projet qui se voulait à la base être
est la vitrine du savoir-faire franco
allemand en matière de nucléaire s'est
transformé au fil du temps en en
bourbier finlandais